[Applause]
here we are
be Wednesday everyone yeah another day
another Biden scandal and shockingly
this time Hunter kept his pants on
which means it must be time for
[Music]
me
thank you
stupid
but before we get to the nitty-gritty
President Biden's got a special message
for us it's a day late but cut him some
slack
hey hey Happy Valentine's make no
mistake freezing jobs
I mean it and you're going to go I mean
come on man it's a true story
all right
well said
I kind of like that but then again I
just ate a bag of expired medications
but at least his heart's in the right
place swimming in a vat of Lipitor in a
fridge
wow how lucky how lucky for him that
every day is Valentine's Day and it
certainly is for his wife Dr Jill talk
about an oral examination
maybe she forgot her tongue depressor
then again she is a doctor I mean but
what is it with biotins and other
people's spouses
they don't just keep it in the family
they keep it in the second family
[Laughter]
savior clapping for when it matters back
to the matter at hand the latest Biden
scandal and it's not about Hunter or his
junk this is about Joe's brother Jimbo
and I hope to God it has nothing to do
with his junk I've seen enough of the
Biden physique to paint it nude from
memory in an art class
The Daily Mail reports Joe younger Joe's
younger brother Jim I think he's only
98. he was hired to negotiate with the
Saudis over a secret 140 million dollar
deal only because his big bro was Veep
at the time affidavits whatever those
are reveal that in 2012 Jimbo was hired
to negotiate with the Saudis on behalf
of an American Construction Company
because of his relationship with Joe no
one would quote dare stiff the brother
of the VP who would be instrumental to
the deal after all the only stiff in
that family is Joe or Hunter after a
handful of his favorite blue pills
apparently Jim was brought in to help
broker payout between the Saudi Kingdom
and The Firm after the Saudis didn't pay
up for work it had done in the 80s funny
this seems like this could have been
handled on People's Court would have
been nice to see Biden on a show besides
the Muppets
Jim reportedly said he was often sent to
meetings to represent the company
because of course the name didn't hurt
to which Joe asked what's so great about
the name Jim
[Laughter]
they had good old Biden family name
didn't hurt so why not spread it around
well unless you're the Forgotten baby
girl of a stripper Knocked Up by Hunter
then it's guarded like an alien's
Underpants in area 51.
so here's yet another instance of the
Biden's trading on their money power and
influence based on their family name
just like Chris Wallace
I don't know where that came from
but they should just start a business
right out in the open the motto when
you're doing the bidding make it a Biden
but it's like I told Bill Hammer when I
walked in on me trying on his shorty
robe I don't believe in coincidences
if memory serves me correctly and it
doesn't Jim Biden and his wife are also
facing scrutiny for alleged involvement
in Hunter's multi-million dollar deal
with a Chinese oil company a deal under
investigation by the feds
the Biden's Shady business dealings are
becoming more common than spy balloons
trading derailments and collapsing
athletes combined and the GOP LED house
oversight committee apparently will
include this as part of their
investigation into the family and those
investigations are worth seeing through
to the end because clearly the family
only cares about money if it's theirs
because when the bidens aren't screwing
strippers they're screwing the whole
country
for years Joe was spouted off in
speeches about how much he cares about
the middle class but under his watch
they continue to get screwed from
inflation to student loans it's the
people Joe claims to care about the most
to end up footing the bill of his own
ineptitude according to the Bureau of
Labor stats eggs are up 70 compared to a
year ago which means a three egg omelet
is probably now more expensive than a
happy ending
and that's without your choice of
toppings
doesn't make sense but it was fun it
does I guess it does
and what and what about the student loan
forgiveness plan you remember the cash
for vote scheme that goes before The
Supreme Court in weeks and if he gets
his way he will spend more than a
trillion dollars for giving student loan
debt and do so without Congressional
approval he'll be blowing up the debt
like it's nordstream to
and the people paying for it will be
those who played by the rules the people
who paid their debts and managed to do
so without asking for handouts talking
about the middle class who Joe claims to
champion before he sacrifices them on
the altar of the woke
Joe what do you have to say for your
brother
no no no look look I don't know about
this stuff I mean I didn't even know I
had a brother I I can't keep track of
this stuff I mean he's Jim Biden I'm Joe
Biden he's younger but I'm better
looking it's not a joke not a joke and
then there's Frank button nobody talks
about him I mean he's another brother
that is Barack Obama my brother from
another mother
you know what the joke is he never to me
here he is let's welcome it's a nice
guess
per square jar could pay off everyone's
student debt outnumbered co-host Emily
campagno
he hails from across the pond and talks
a bit like James Bond best-selling
author in Fox News contributor Douglas
Murray
she's like a bag of popcorn light salty
and can fit in the microwave Fox News
contributor Kat Tim
and finally his lunchbox came from The
Container Store my massive sidekick in
the NWA World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Emily you claim to be a lawyer I have
not seen proof but we'll go with it for
this show we needed a lawyer so he's
denying this this guy Jim never heard of
him uh what do you make of this try to
boil this entire thing down using your
legal background in 30 to 45 seconds
I will say the most Salient points that
viewers need to understand is that over
eight years ago now seven eight years
ago actually well prior to that years
years and past the brother of the then
sitting vice president was employed for
a private contract issue with a
government of Saudi Arabia and that
dispute was over 140 million dollars and
when it was settled how it was settled
was they said well we're just going to
award you numerous future contracts so
what do you think all the participants
got they obviously got a cut right and
at that time the director of enforcement
of the the U.S treasury Department
interviewed Jim Biden in his home do you
think average Americans get that that
honor do you think they get the pleasure
of being interviewed by the director of
enforcement at the U.S treasury
Department in the comfort of their own
living room and then have eight years
past where no one hears about it the
only reason we're hearing about this now
is because thank goodness for house
oversight committee chair James Comer
who has this affidavit in his possession
and all of these files that are exposing
the fact that four years now which we
already knew this Biden family has been
capitalizing on their name to the tune
of millions and millions of dollars
including China that you mentioned
earlier and sacrificing National
Security and sovereignty and I hope for
once there will be accountability and my
faith is in the House GOP LED very good
well done
just one follow-up question what exactly
is an affidavit I mean is it just a
piece of paper why do you have to keep
saying affidavit because it means that
you've like sworn that to it to be true
it's almost like a written oath like in
court it's the same thing like a sworn
testimony on a piece of paper see this
is like when you pinky swear yeah
in your case that's not a pinky
[Laughter]
what do you hear about the Biden family
the more it's all the stuff they accuse
the Trump family of doing yeah you know
what I mean you're always kind enough
when you introduce me to mention that
I'm a migrant yes illegal migrant yes
but yeah but a migrant nonetheless are
you staying for free in any hotel I'd
love to they never offer it but that's
because if you weren't it'd be really
weird that you talked like that
there's so many things just saying and
anyhow but you always remind everyone of
that but I just wanna for once I refer
to it myself there's a scandal going on
in my country of birth today there is a
politician who charged the taxpayer 100
pounds that they shouldn't have charged
the taxpayer it's huge it is it's a
meltdown in Westminster now I say this
because we are so used in America to
corruption on a gargantuan scale like
most other countries most other
democracies you know like literally
governments fall over like you know
somebody put in for a Twix that they
charge the taxpay for and they're off
they go and only in America have we put
up with a situation where the first
family is routinely involved in deals
worth millions and millions of dollars
okay kind of a kind of corruption is
just not common and we've become used to
it's a hundred pounds is 18 and
and six shillings something like that
yes
did you ever have to sweep a chimney
when you were a kid
I I practically grew up in a chimney
I'm sorry that's how I end my way to
come to America
I love you and Oliver thank you very
much
Lisa yes
um the cat
were you um infuriated by this news
confused by this news or Jaded by this
news like a little bit of jaded and also
infuriated because as you say this is
par for the course you know it's like oh
wow people in power are abusing it to
benefit themselves but it's the thing
about Biden which you mentioned Greg
it's the fact that he talks all the time
about how you know I the wealthy need to
pay their fair share and all this other
stuff and it's like listen while you are
getting rich and making your family Rich
you are making it very difficult for me
to get rich I'm serious like the amount
in taxes and then the money they leave
you with is worth so much less like I
don't even need 140 million dollars of
Saudi oil money or whatever I would like
to buy an apartment like that with more
than a couple rooms in it would be
really nice in the city where I work
that's not possible
exactly right exactly yeah and it's like
okay you know I don't have any Saudi oil
money so you know what's what's my fair
share of the Saudi oil money that you're
just it's crazy to me how you could know
that you're doing this and then still
stand up there and demonize people who
want to keep the money that they earn
themselves an honest way
she really wants that Saudi money Tyrus
yeah you've never offered me anything
call the big guy
that's not me
but it is this you suddenly realize this
is why Biden's got into politics right
because they can pull these levers that
we it has to be a reason why he stayed
in the job for 30 years he sucked that
so at least we now know why
um but this is all a pretty red ribbon
for me Gutfeld that ties it all together
we now know all the answers for
everything that happened in the last six
years there was a report
all the all the stuff all the peeing in
beds in Russia and all the all the stuff
that was going on and Deals and all that
they handed that packet and the
Democrats just said let's just erase
that top name right there
Donald Trump uh Donald Trump with a go
that's exactly what it was because
everything that Trump was accused of
this dude did well well no it was sloppy
it was it was everybody knew they just
switched a couple names here and there
and they can impeach everybody so let's
just because it was probably written in
pencil anyways let's just erase it put
his name back on and then impeach him
it's true actually but you know what
that steel dossier does can't hold a
candle to the hunter laptop because on
her laptop is got the sex and it's got
the money okay I told you before he was
young and innocent and that was the
camera used by the porn director it was
not his fault
I stand corrected or rather I sit
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else